vamos a encontrar el límite cuando
extiende a 0 de fx por hdx así que
observa que por acá tenemos las gráficas
de igual a fx
hdx y ahora vamos a usar nuestras
propiedades de los límites una de las
propiedades de los límites nos dice que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que el
límite cuando se tiende a cero de fx que
a su vez multiplica al límite cuando h
tiende a cero de hd x así que vamos a
pensar por separado en cuánto vale cada
uno de estos límites primero vamos a
pensar en fx entonces en fx observen que
la función x igual a 0 no está definida
pero podemos ver que cuando nos
aproximamos por la izquierda de la
función parece que nos estamos
aproximando al valor de menos 1 y cuando
nos aproximamos por la derecha de la
función parece que nos estamos
aproximando también al valor de menos 1
así que el límite cuando existen de 0 de
esta función
fx va a ser menos 1 cuando nos
aproximamos por la izquierda nos estamos
aproximando a menos 1 cuando nos
aproximamos por la derecha el valor
la función parece estarse aproximando a
-1 entonces va a ser menos 1 ahora que
hay de hd x bueno primero observa que la
función si está definida en x igual a 0
parece que es igual a 1 y también
observa que el límite es igual a 1
podemos ver que cuando nos aproximamos a
x igual a 0 por la izquierda de la
función esto se aproxima a 1 y cuando
nos aproximamos a x igual a 0 por la
derecha de la función ésta también se
aproxima a 1 y tiene todo el sentido del
mundo porque esta función está definida
en x igual a 0 y además es una función
continua entonces el límite cuando x
aproxima a 0 va a ser igual al valor de
la función así que esto es igual a 1 y
entonces me quedan menos 1 x 1 lo cual
es igual a menos 1 y entonces ya
acabamos este primer ejercicio
todo esto es igual a menos 1 muy bien
vamos a hacer algunos más y para eso voy
a mover la pantalla y ahora vamos a
trabajar el siguiente
el límite cuando x tiende a -3 de menos
2 por fx + 3 por hdx y una vez más
podemos usar nuestras propiedades de los
límites así que sabemos que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que el límite
cuando x tiende a menos 3 de menos 2 por
fx más el límite cuando x tiene al menos
tres de 3 x hdx y también sabemos que
esto es exactamente lo mismo si sacamos
las constantes que menos 2 que
multiplican al límite cuando x tiende a
menos 3 de fx podemos sacar el escalar y
también podemos sacar el escalar justo
aquí y me quedarían tres veces el límite
cuando x tiende a menos 3 de hdx ahora
solamente nos falta encontrar cuánto
vale el límite cuando x tiende a menos 3
de fx y el límite cuando x tiende a
menos 3 de hd x
así que primero trabajaré con fx cuando
nos aproximamos a menos 3 por el lado
izquierdo me parece que se está
aproximando al valor de 3 y cuando nos
aproximamos por el lado derecho aparece
que la función se aproxima a cero así
que nuestros límites por la izquierda y
por la derecha se están aproximando a
valores diferentes entonces este límite
no existe este límite no existe y de
hecho el límite dgt x si existen pero ya
que este límite no existe
no necesitamos encontrar el otro límite
para poder decir que todo este límite
completo todo este límite no va a
existir déjame ponerlo no existe los
límites de los que está compuesto este
límite necesitan existir ya que este es
un límite de una combinación de
funciones así que cada una de sus partes
necesita existir para que en total la
suma escalada de estos dos límites
exista espero que quede claro porque
vamos a hacer uno más para eso déjame
mover la pantalla y ahora vamos a
trabajar con este equipo
queremos el límite cuando extiende a 0
de hd x entre g x ya sabes parece que
tenemos funciones continuas así que una
vez más usando nuestras propiedades de
los límites esto va a ser lo mismo que
el límite de ht x cuanto x tiende a cero
esto a su vez dividido entre el límite
dgt x cuando x tiende a cero ahora
empecemos con h cuál es el límite de hd
x cuando extiende a 0 bueno veamos por
ejemplo cuando nos aproximamos a 0 por
la izquierda
nuestra función parece estar
aproximándose a 4 y cuando nos
aproximamos a x igual a 0 por la derecha
nuestra función parece que se está
aproximando al mismo valor a 4 y además
es justo lo que vale la función en x
igual a 0 y esto tiene mucho sentido ya
que es una función continua así que en
este caso el límite cuando nos
aproximamos a x igual a 0 va a ser el
mismo que el valor de la función en x
igual a cero así que ya tenemos el
numerador
el numerador de esta división va a ser
igual a 4 ahora vayamos con gdx y
pensemos cuál es el límite de gx cuando
x tiende a cero así que por la izquierda
parece que cuando x se aproxima a 0 el
valor que toma la función es 0 y cuando
x se aproxima a 0 por la derecha el
valor de la función también se está
aproximando a 0 de hecho que de 0
también es 0 y eso tiene sentido el
límite y el valor real de la función es
el mismo ya que es una función continua
así que en el denominador de esta
fracción voy a tener 0 pero ahora
tenemos una situación extraña tenemos
que tomar 4 y dividirlo entre 0 así que
todo este límite de aquí no va a existir
ya que no podemos tomar 4 y dividirlo
entre 0 y este es un caso muy
interesante porque aunque el límite de
hd x cuando extiende a 0 existe y el
límite deje de x cuando x tiende a cero
existen no podemos dividir 4 entre 0 así
que todo este límite completo que
buscábamos no existe y déjame escribirlo
no existen y de hecho si tuvieran que
graficar hdx entre gdx podrían ver mucho
más claro que este límite en definitiva
no existen y si hacen esto serían
capaces de verlo gráficamente